winter is coming and it's hit the ground
running two swords now as with my
episode by episode reviews that I did
for season three I'm gonna try and keep
these spoiler free at least as far as
this season content goes I'm gonna be
talking freely about spoilers from the
first three season so if you're not
caught up you've been warned
I complained last time about how it took
really about three episodes in before
things really started happening this
time it really feels like everything's
moving forward right off the bat we are
an acquired or period because the war
for the Iron Throne is not completely
over but most of the important parties
are kind of out of it now the only one
who's still trying to make a grab for
the throne is Stannis and he's laying
low at the moment and yet there's still
plenty of stuff going on here at King's
Landing we get introduced to a brand new
character this guy I like him I like him
a lot and that's actually really
difficult to pull off because
introducing new characters four seasons
into a running show if they don't
connect every time you go to them it's
like well why am i spending time with
this new person who I don't know yet
when I could be spending time with the
characters that I know I like so new
characters tend to start at a
disadvantage so we get one that works
right out the gate like this guy does
that's worthy of some serious praise
he's intriguing he's charismatic he's
got a really legitimate grudge against
the Lannisters and I'm really gonna be
interested to see how he plays out
seeing what's going on with Jaime
Lannister is interesting obviously he's
cleaned up a little bit since last time
we saw him but they're also taking him
in some interesting directions and doing
it fairly subtly something shifted in
him and the people around him we can
sort of tell that to and it was really
interesting seeing the interaction with
him and searcy because it just
reiterates what a [ __ ] she is and it
lays more groundwork for him to have a
little bit more character growth because
you know he's gone through all this
effort to come back to be with searcy
but it's not what it was and she makes
it plain that it can't be what it was so
where does he go from here he also has a
nice interaction with Brienne of Tarth I
complained about the pairing of these
two and I
might have been wrong I think I might
have been reading that potential
romantic angle into it and it may not
have been there cuz there's no sign of
it here which I'm so grateful for their
interactions completely devoid of
romantic interest but the chemistry is
still there and I'm loving it Sansa's
taking a slight backward step for me she
was starting to go somewhere interesting
in the last couple episodes of last
season after she got married off but now
she's dealing with the aftermath of even
more members of her family getting
killed so now she's back in to moping
again it's a necessary step for her I'm
just hoping that we can get her through
this and get her back onto the way to
being interesting and you know I really
hate to say this Tyrians boring me a
little bit he seems to be just be stuck
in the cycle of people not supporting
him and just being sort of down on his
luck in a lot of ways and shey factors
into that and I'm kind of done with her
at this point really but I just I keep
waiting for Terry to start to pull
himself out of the situation that he's
there because he's been stuck in this
master of coin role with and not doing
too much else for a while now and I just
I want to see a little bit of a shake-up
with him up at the wall Jon Snow's back
with the Nights Watch can actually
something interesting happened I wasn't
bored with Jon Snow there's just been
some little adjustments with his
performance there's just something a
little bit more worldly a little bit
more jaded about him and he's bringing a
new attitude and a new sense of this
character that I'm actually liking he's
not just that noble slightly naive guy
that he's been up to this point I really
feel like the experiences that he had
last season are really starting to
finally shape him into a character that
is interesting to me Daenerys is still
holding very strong she's maintaining
her sense of power they've been some
hints that the Dragons might not quite
be at her Beck and call quite as much as
we thought initially but you're really
just getting a sense of power with her
you really are kind of getting the
feeling that everything else going on
with the Iron Throne up in Westeros is
just wasting time until she comes in and
wipes everybody out which is a hard
thing to balance because that could make
it feel like look can we just get to
that part already because it's
inevitable and said it just they're
building the anticipation for that
really well I am kind of hope
she at least gets on her way towards
Westeros by the end of this season
because they have stretched it out a
little bit up to this point Thank You
veneris though they did a little bit of
an odd thing with her new lieutenant
Daario naharis and it's a little bit
jarring because you see last season he
was played by this guy okay
now this season he's played by this guy
it's a little jarring when he actually
showed up even though they said his name
I was looking I'm going who is that and
I get that they had to recast you know
actors become unavailable for whatever
reason but the look is such a drastic
shift that it really did throw me off I
mean this is not the first row that the
wreath that they've recast we're gonna
get our third actor in the role of the
mountain in this season because first it
was this guy then it was this guy and
now we're gonna be getting this guy but
you can see consistent look across the
board this is much more of a shift and
you don't beyond just the look this guy
he's not bringing the same feel to the
character the guy who they had in last
season hey-ya added this little bit
honestly it's just kind of strangeness
to him you didn't quite figure him out
you got this sense that he had an
attraction or romantic interest in
Daenerys but he also felt like there's
something else going on beyond that that
you couldn't quite put your finger on
right now it just feels like straight-up
romantic interest and there's nothing
else on the cards with this guy but
let's talk the real highlight of this
thing are you stark and the Hound
they got paired together at the end of
the last season and now they're
traveling together and there's just so
much good stuff here just the dynamic of
the two of them together is great in the
first place The Hound who's always been
around but hasn't really gotten to do
all that much besides stand there and
look badass and kill a few people for a
while he really gets a shiny moments in
this episode but really truly Arya if
she continues the trajectory that she's
on right now she may actually surpass
Tyrion for my favorite character in this
whole show last season she had her first
kill she got blood on her hands for the
first time and the things that that is
now bringing out of her and the way she
sort of adjusting to what her life is
now I'm really really enjoying overall
just a
really good strong start to the season I
like the plot threads that seem to be
getting laid out for the things that
we're gonna be seeing for this season
Daenerys she's now on our way to another
slaver city so they better be watching
their ass we're headed towards Joffrey's
wedding and I'm liking the political
intrigue that we got going on in King's
Landing because of all that the
wildlings are getting ready to storm the
wall of course aria as I talked about
before this is all good stuff and I'm
liking the view that I've got for season
four right now this looks like it's
gonna be really good so let me ask you
if you saw this episode which of the
plot threads that got laid out here are
you most excited to see falling through
and carried through throughout the
season leave something out in the
comments let's talk about it until next
time this council is adjourned